simply learn welcomes you to machine
learning versus deep learning versus
artificial intelligence some of the most
exciting technologies evolving in
today's world my name is Richard
Kirchner and I'll be hosting this talk
or simply learned before we start
covering the basics of these three
topics and how they connect and how they
are different let's just look at a few
examples so we get an understanding of
what's going on here's an example of
artificial intelligence in today's world
Amazon echo Amazon echo is a wonderful
tool we can go in there and you can say
hey Alexa what's the temperature in
Chicago and the Amazon echo then
translates that into zeros and ones and
something the computer understands then
it comes in and processes that
information to identify what you're
asking and what you need and where to
get that information and then it comes
back and says the current temperature in
Chicago is six degrees Fahrenheit or
whatever it is at the moment so this is
a wonderful example of artificial
intelligence that we're using right now
today where that's at as far as a
commercial deployment machine learning a
machine learning example out there is
Google you're on your Google search
engine it comes up you spend a lot of
time on the first link you come into and
you read the page and Google looks at
that and says okay he spent five minutes
on this
let's give it a thumbs up and then you
go to the second page and the third page
you just kind of skip over them and
glanced at him for a couple seconds and
Google says I wasn't interested in those
pages let's give them a thumbs down so
this is a good example of machine
learning as it starts guessing what you
like and what you don't like so it gives
you more information along which are
going to read and actually use and then
we have an example of deep learning in
this example we have a black and white
image it comes in two and in this case a
neural network some people like to call
it a magic box because you really it's
hard to follow all that's going on in
there there's all these different
weights and connections and nodes and
then it comes out and colors the beach
ball the people the background what's
going on in here as the black and white
image goes in to this neural
work and before it's ever gone in the
neural network has looked at all these
different pictures on the web or
wherever it pulls the data from and it's
already itemized them and kind of
separated them that we have some that
look like beach balls we have something
that look like people in a program set
so that when the black and white image
comes in it goes okay that piece right
there resembles this and all these four
other photos and the neural network is a
able to identify that and then color the
beach ball with the colors that you see
on there so it gives it this is really
wonderful cuz they did a wonderful job
coloring this picture and that's the
full set up is where the deep learning
example comes in and the usually center
around neural networks so we looked at a
few examples what's in it for you first
we're going to talk about human versus
artificial intelligence this is very
important because this is our marker we
as humans are amazing and so we want to
understand how artificial intelligence
compares and what it does that it can
accelerate above humans and how it can
integrate with the human experience what
is machine learning and deep learning
all about are they really all that
different we'll have a few more examples
in here and then we'll talk a little bit
about types of AI and machine learning
and comparing machine learning and deep
learning and finally a glimpse into the
future human versus artificial
intelligence humans are amazing let's
just face it we're amazing creatures
we're all over the planet we're
exploring every niche and nook we've
gone to the moon we got into outer space
we're just amazing creatures we're able
to use the available information to make
decisions to communicate with other
people identify patterns and data
remember what people have said adapt to
new situations so let's take a look at
this so you can get a picture you are a
human being so you know it's like to be
human let's take a look at artificial
intelligence versus the human artificial
intelligence develops computer systems
that can accomplish tasks that require
human intelligence so we're looking at
this one of the things that computers
can do is they can provide more accurate
results
this is very important recently I did a
project on cancer where as identifying
markers and as a human being you look at
that and you might be looking at all the
different images in the data that comes
off of them and say I like this person
so I want to give them a very good
outlook and the next person you might
not like so you want to give a bad
outlook well with artificial
intelligence you're gonna get a
consistent prediction of what's going to
come out interacts with humans using
their natural language we've seen that
is probably the biggest development
feature right now that's in the
commercial market that everybody gets to
use as we saw with the example of Alexa
they learn from their mistakes and adapt
to new environments so we see this loli
coming in more and more and they learn
from the data and automate repetitive
learning repetitive learning has a lot
to do with the neural networks you have
to program thousands upon thousands of
pictures in there and it's all automated
so as today's computers evolved it's
very quick and easy and affordable to do
this what is machine learning and deep
learning all about imagine this say you
had some time to waste not that any of
us really have a lot of time anymore to
just waste in today's world and you're
sitting by the road and you have a whole
lot and a whole lot of time passes by
there's a few hours and suddenly you
wonder how many cars buses trucks and so
on passed by in the six hours now
chances are you're not gonna sit by the
road for six hours and count buses cars
and trucks unless you're working for the
city and you're trying to do City
Planning and you want to know hey do we
need to add a new truck route maybe we
need a bicycle length to have a lot of
bicyclists here that kind of thing so
maybe City Planning would be great for
this machine learning well the way
machine learning works is we have
labeled data with features okay so you
have a truck or a car a motorcycle a bus
or a bicycle and each one of those are
labeled it comes in and based on those
labels and comparing those features it
gives you an answer it's a bicycle it's
a truck it's a motorcycle this look a
little bit more in-depth on this and the
model here it actually the features
we're looking at would be like the tires
someone's sister and figures out what a
tire looks like takes a lot of work if
you try to try to figure a difference
between a car tire a bicycle tire
motorcycle tire so in the machine
learning field this could take a long
time if you're gonna do each individual
aspect of a car and try to get a result
on there and that's what they did do it
was a very this is still used on smaller
amounts of data where you figure out
what those features are and then you
label them deep learning so with deep
learning one of our solutions is to take
a very large unlabeled data set and we
put that into a training model using
artificial neural networks and then that
goes into the neural network itself when
we create a neural network and you'll
see the arrows are actually kind of
backward but which actually is a nice
point because when we train the neural
network we put the bicycle in and then
it comes back and says if it's a truck
it comes back and says well you need to
change that to bicycle and then it
changes all those weights going backward
they call it back propagation and let it
know it's a bicycle and that's how it
learns
once you've trained the neural network
you then put the new data in and they
call this testing the model so you need
to have some data you've kept off to the
side where you know the answer to and
you take that and you provide the
required output and you say ok is this
is this neural network working correctly
did identify a bike as a bike a truck as
a truck a motorcycle as a motorcycle
let's just take a little closer look at
that determining what objects are
present in the data so how does deep
learning do this and here we have the
image of the bike it's 28 by 28 pixels
that's a lot of information there could
you imagine trying to guess that this is
a bicycle image by looking at each one
of those pixels and trying to figure out
what's around it and we actually do that
as human beings it's pretty amazing we
know what a bicycle is and even though
it comes in is all this information and
what this looks like is the image comes
in it converts it into a bunch of
different nodes in this case there's a
lot more than what they show here and it
goes through these different layers and
outcomes that says ok this is a bicycle
a lot of times they call this the man
black box why because as we watch it go
across here all these weights and all
the math behind this and it's not it's a
little complicated on the math side you
really don't need to know that when
you're programming or doing working with
the deep learning but it's like magic
you don't know you really can't figure
out what's going to come out by looking
what's in each one of those dots and
each one of those lines are firing and
what's going in between them so we like
to call it the magic box so that's where
deep learning comes in and in the end it
comes up and you have this whole neural
network it comes up and says ok we fire
all these different pixels and we
connects all these different dots and
gives them different weights and it says
ok this is a bicycle and that's how we
determine what the object is present in
the data with deep learning machine
learning we're going to take a step into
machine learning here and you'll see how
these fit together in a minute the
system is able to make predictions or
take decisions based on past data that's
very important for machine learning is
that we're looking at stuff and based on
what's been there before we're creating
a decision on there we're creating
something out of there we're coloring a
beach ball we're telling you what the
weather is in Chicago what's nice about
machine learning is a very powerful
processing capability it's quick and
accurate outcomes so you get results
right away once you program the system
the results are very fast and the
decisions and predictions are better
they're more accurate they're consistent
you can analyze very large amounts of
data some of these data things that
they're analyzing now our petabytes and
terabytes of data it would take hundreds
of people hundreds of years to go
through some of this data and do the
same thing that the machine learning can
do in a very short period of time and
it's inexpensive compared to hiring
hundreds of people so because a very
affordable way to move into the future
is to apply the machine learning to
whatever businesses you're working on
and deep learning systems think and
learn like humans using artificial
neural networks again it's like a magic
box performance improves with more data
so the more data the deep learning gets
the more it gives you better results its
scalability so you can scale it up you
can scale it
down you can increase what you're
looking at currently you know we're
limited by the amount of computer
processing power as to how big that can
get but that envelope continually gets
pushed every day on what it can do
problem solved in an end-to-end method
so instead of having to break it apart
and you have the first piece coming in
and you identify tires and the second
piece is identifying labeling handlebars
and then you bring that together that if
it has handlebars and tires it's a
bicycle and if it has something that
looks like a large square is probably a
truck the neural networks does this all
in one network you don't really know
what's going on in all those weights and
all those little bubbles but it does it
pretty much in one package that's why
the neural network systems are so big
nowadays and coming in to their own best
features are selected by the system and
it this is important they kind of put
its on a bullet on the side here it's a
subset of machine learning this is
important we talk about deep learning it
is a form of machine learning there's
lots of other forms of machine learning
data analysis but this is the newest and
biggest thing that they apply to a lot
of different packages and they use all
the other machine learning tools
available to work with it and it's very
fast to test you put in your information
you then have your group of tests and
then you held some aside you see how
does it do it's very quick to test it
and see what's going on with your deep
learning and your neural network are
they really all that different
AI versus machine learning versus deep
learning concepts of AI so we have a
concepts of ai ai
you'll see natural language processing
machine learning and approach to creat
artificial intelligence so as one of the
subsets of artificial intelligence
knowledge representation automated
reasoning computer vision robotics
machine learning versus AI versus deep
learning or AI and machine learning and
deep learning so we look at this we have
AI with machine learning and deep
learning and so we're going to put them
all together we find out that AI is the
big picture we have a collection of
books and goes through some deep
learning
the digital data is analyzed text mining
comes through the particular book you're
looking for or maybe it's a genre books
is identified and in this case we have a
robot that goes and gives a book to the
patron I have yet to be at a library
that has a robot bring me a book but
that will be cool when it happens so
we'll look at some of the pieces here
this information goes into there's as
far as this example the translation of
the handwritten printed data to digital
form that's pretty hard to do that's
pretty hard to go in there and translate
hundreds and hundreds of books and
understand what they're trying to say if
you've never read them so in this case
we used a deep learning because you can
already use examples where they've
already classified a lot of books and
then they can compare those texts and
say oh okay this is a book on automotive
repair this is a book on robotic
building the digital data is in analyzed
then we have more text mining using
machine learning so maybe we'd use a
different program to do a basic classify
what you're looking for and say oh
you're looking for auto repair and
computers so you're looking for
automated cars once it's identified then
of course it brings you the book so
here's a nice summation of what we were
just talking about AI with machine
learning and deep learning deep learning
is a subset of machine learning which is
a subset of artificial intelligence so
you can look at artificial intelligence
as a big picture how does this compare
to the human experience in either doing
the same thing as a human we do or it
does it better than us and machine
learning which has a lot of tools is
something that learns from data past
experiences it's programmed it's a comes
in there and it says hey we already had
these five things happen the sixth one
should be about the same and then
there's a lot of tools in machine
learning
but deep learning then is a very
specific tool in machine learning it's
the artificial neural network which
handles large amounts of data and is
able to take huge pools of experiences
pictures and ideas and bring them
together real life examples
artificial intelligence news generation
very common nowadays is it goes through
there and finds the news articles or
generates the news based upon the news
feats or the back end coming in and says
okay let's give you the actual news
based on this there's all the different
things Amazon echo they have a number of
different prime music on there of course
there's also the Google command and
there's also Cortana there's tons of
smart home devices now where we can ask
it to turn the TV on or play music for
us that's all artificial intelligence
from front to back you're having a human
experience with these computers and
these objects that are connected to the
processing machine learning spam
detection very common machine learning
doesn't really have the human
interaction part so this is the part
where it goes and says okay that's a
spam that's not a spam and it puts it in
your spam folder search engine result
refining another example of machine
learning where as it looks at your
different results and and it is able to
categorize them as far as it's had the
most hits this is the least viewed this
has 5 stars
you know however they want to weight it
all exactly good example is a machine
learning and then the deep learning deep
learning another example is as you have
like a exit sign in this case is
translating it into french sortie I hope
I said that right the neural network has
been programmed with all these different
words and images and so it's able to
look at the exit in the middle and it
goes okay we won't know what that is in
French and it's able to push that out in
France French and learn how to do that
and then we have chat BOTS
I remember when Microsoft first had
their little paperclip that was like a
long time ago they came up and you would
type in there and chat with it these are
growing you know it's nice to just be
able to ask a question and it comes up
and gives you the answer and instead of
it being were you just doing a search on
certain words it's now able to start
linking those words together and form a
sentence in that chat box types of AI
and machine learning types of artificial
intelligence this and the next few
slides are really important so one of
the types of artificial intelligence is
reactive machines systems that only
react they don't form memories they
don't have past experiences they have
something that happens to them and they
react to it my washing machine is one of
those if I put a ton of clothes in it
and they had all clumped on one side it
automatically adds a weight to resit ER
it so that my washing machine is
actually a reactive machine working with
whatever the load is and keeps it nice
and so when it spins it doesn't go
thumping against the side limited memory
another form of artificial intelligence
systems look into the past information
is added over a period of time and
information is short-lived we're talking
about this and you look at like a neural
network that's been programmed to
identify cars it doesn't remember all
those pictures it has no memory as far
as the hundreds of pictures you process
through it all it has is this is the
pattern I use to identify cars as a
final output for that neural network we
looked at so when they talk about
limited memory this is what they're
talking about they're talking about I've
created this based on all these things
but I'm not going to remember anyone
specifically theory of mind systems
being able to understand human emotions
and how they affect decision-making to
adjust their behaviors according to
their human understanding this is
important because this is our page mark
this is how we know whether it is an
artificial intelligence or not is it
interacting with humans in a way that we
can understand without that interaction
is just an object so we talked about
theory of mind we really understand how
it interfaces that whole if you're in
web development user experience would be
the term I would put in there so the
theory of mine would be user experience
how's the whole UI connected together
and one of the final things as we get
into artificial intelligence assistants
being aware of themselves understanding
their internal States and predicting
other people's feelings and act
appropriately so as artificial
intelligence continues to program
we see ones they're trying to understand
well what makes people happy how would
they increase our happiness how would
they keep themselves from breaking down
if something's broken inside they have
that self-awareness to be able to fix it
and just based on all that information
predicting which action would work the
best what would help people if I know
that you're having a cup of coffee first
thing in the morning is what makes you
happy as a robot I might make you a cup
of coffee every morning at the same time
to help your life and help you grow
that'd be the self-awareness is being
able to know all those different things
types of machine learning and like I
said on the last slide this is very
important this is very important if you
decide to go in and get certified in
machine learning or know more about it
these are the three primary types of
machine learning
the first one is supervised learning
systems are able to predict future
outcome based on past data requires both
an input and an output to be given to
the model for it to be trained so in
this case we're looking at anything
where you have a hundred images of a
bicycle
and that 100 images you know our bicycle
so it's their preset someone already
looked at all hundred images that said
these are pictures of bicycles and so
the computer learns from those and then
it's given another picture and maybe the
next picture is a bicycle and it says oh
that resembles all these other bicycles
so it's a bicycle and the next one is a
car that's not a bicycle that would be
supervised learning because we had to
train it we had to supervise it
unsupervised learning systems are able
to identify hidden patterns from the
input data provided by making the data
more readable and organized the patterns
similarities or anomalies become more
evident
you'll heard the term cluster how do you
cluster things together some of these
things go together some of these don't
this is unsupervised we can look at an
image and start pulling the different
pieces of the image out because they
aren't the same the human all the parts
of the human are not the same as a fuzzy
tree behind them so slightly out of
focus which is not the same as the beach
ball
it's unsupervised because we never told
it what a beach ball was we never told
them what the human was and we never
told it that those were trees all we
told it was hey separate this picture by
things that don't match and things that
do match and come together and finally
there's reinforcement learning systems
are given no training it learns on the
basis of the reward punishment it
received for performing its last action
it helps increase the efficiency of a
tool function or a program reinforced
learning a reinforcement learning is
kind of you give it a yes or no yes you
gave me the right response no you didn't
and then it looks at that and says oh
okay so based on this data coming in
what I gave you was a wrong response so
next time I'll give you a different one
comparing machine learning and deep
learning so remember that deep learning
is a subcategory of machine learning so
it's one of the many tools and so they
were grouping a ton of machine learning
tools all together linear regression
k-means clustering there's all kinds of
cool tools out there you can use in
machine learning enables machines to
take decisions to make decisions on
their own based on past data enables
machines to make decisions with the help
of artificial neural networks so it's
doing the same thing but we're using an
artificial neural network as opposed to
one of the more traditional machine
learning tools needs only a small amount
of training data this is very important
when you're talking about machine
learning they're usually not talking
about huge amounts of data we were
talking about maybe your spreadsheet
from your business and your totals for
the end of the year when you're talking
about neural networks you usually need a
large amount of data to train the data
so there's a lot of training involved if
you have under 500 points of data that's
probably not gonna go into machine
learning or maybe you have like the case
on one of the things five hundred points
of data and thirty different fields
starts getting really confusing there
and artificial intelligence or machine
learning and the deep learning aspect
really shines when you get to that
larger data this really complex works
well on a low-end systems so a lot of
the machine learning tools out there you
can run on your laptop with no problem
and do the calculations there where with
the machine learning usually needs a
higher end system to work it takes a lot
more processing power to build those
neural networks and to train them goes
through a lot of data we're talking
about the general machine learning tools
mostly
features need to be identified in
advanced and manually coded there's a
lot of human work on here the machine
learns the features from the data it is
provided so again it's like a magic box
you don't have to know what a tire is it
figures it out for you
the problem is divided in two parts and
solved individually and then combined so
machine learning you usually have all
these different tools and use different
tools for different parts and the
problem is solved in an end-to-end
manner so you only have one neural
network or two neural networks that is
bringing the data in and putting it out
it's not going through a lot of
different processes to get there and
remember you can put machine learning
and deep learning together so you don't
always have just the deep learning
solving the problem I have is sawing one
piece of the puzzle with regular machine
learning a muslim' machine learning
tools out there they take longer to test
and understand how they work and what
the deep learning is pretty quick once
you build that neural network you test
it and you know so we're dealing with
very crisp rules limited resources you
have to really explain how the decision
was made when you use most machine
learning tools but when you use the deep
learning tool inside the machine
learning tools the system takes care of
it based on its own logic and reasoning
and again it's like a magic black box
you really don't know how it came up
with the answer you just know it come up
with the right answer
like glimpse into the future so a quick
glimpse into the future artificial
intelligence be using it to detecting
crimes before they happen humanoid AI
helpers which we already have a lot of
there'll be more and more maybe it'll
actually be Androids I'd be cool to have
an Android that comes and get stuff out
of my fridge for me
machine learning increasing efficiency
in healthcare that's really big in all
the forms of machine learning better
marketing techniques any of these things
if we get into the sciences it's just
off the scale machine learning and
artificial intelligence go everywhere
and then the sub category deep learning
increased personalization so what's
really nice about the deep learning is
it's gonna start now catering to you
they'll be one of the things we see more
and more of and we'll have more of a
hyper-intelligent personal assistant I'm
excited about that what we have learned
so far we cover
at artificial intelligence in this case
the AI versus the human we did a lot of
that so we have a page marker of human
interaction we discussed machine
learning and all their different parts
and then we discussed the deep learning
aspect we went into AI and machine
learning and deep learning how they're
all sub categories of each other
very important to remember that
artificial intelligence is a big picture
machine learning is a category in
artificial intelligence and then deep
learning is a tool in machine learning
we talked of all the aspects in the
machine learning and deep learning and
how they compare and we took a quick
glimpse into the future and all the
different I'm sure you can come up with
many more examples of where it's coming
out in our future we looked at a few of
them so you have some ideas of where
this is going and all the different
wonderful opportunities are going to
come out with it I would like to thank
you for more information visit us at
wwlp.com if you have any questions or
like to give us feedback please use the
comments down below thank you again and
have a wonderful day hi there if you
like this video subscribe to the simply
learn youtube channel and click here to
watch similar videos Dinard up and get
certified click here